SUCH CLASSICS AS THE PRINCESS
FINAL TAP, THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON AND ON.
ROB REINER IS EXTREMELY
OUTSPOKEN ON POLITICS.
FORTH.
BE HERE.
WE RAN INTO EACH OTHER AT A
RESTAURANT LAST NIGHT AND NOW
WE'RE TALKING HERE.
>> Laura: PURPLE TERRITORY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE SHOULD HAVE NEGOTIATED THIS
THING MAYBE WE WOULDN'T HAVE A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
>> Laura: THAT'S THE FIRST THING
HE SAID LAST NIGHT, ARE THEY
GOING TO SHUT THE GOVERNMENT
DOWN?
I SAID I'M HERE IN L.A., LET'S
TALK ABOUT HOLLYWOOD.
HE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT HOLE
PARTICULARS.
YOU STARTED THIS COMMITTEE WITH
DAVID FROMM, ABOUT INVESTIGATING
THE RUSSIA CONNECTION.
I READ ABOUT IT, YOU KNOW, BE
HONEST, I LAUGHED, WHAT THE
HECK, HOLLYWOOD GUY, THE GUY WHO
WRITES FOR THE ATLANTIC ARE
CAN'T DO?
>> WE HAVE A REALLY GOOD
ADVISORY BOARD.
>> Laura: BIG FANS OF TRUMP.
>> JOHN BRENNAN HAS BEEN
INVOLVED.
SO WE'VE GOT, YOU KNOW, PRETTY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, I JUST FELT
THAT THE PUBLIC WAS NOT REALLY
GRAPHITY.
WARFARE HAS CHANGED.
WE HAVE THIS CYBER WAR, YOU
CAN'T FEEL.
YOU KNOW, IF WE HAD BEEN
ATTACKED, LET'S SAY, THE
BUILDINGS GET KNOCKED DOWN OR A
BOMB BLOWS UP IN NEW YORK CITY,
EVERYBODY SAYS OH, WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING.
>> Laura: WHY NOT RUSSIA, WHY
NOT CHINA?
WHY NOT JUST RUSSIA?
>> LISTEN, THERE'S A LOT OF
CYBER --
VERY EFFECTIVE WHAT THEY PULLED
OFF.
IT'S NOTHING NEW, I MEAN --
>> Laura: WHAT YOU MEAN WHAT
THEY PULL OFF?
ELECTION, HILLARY DIDN'T LOSE
BECAUSE OF RUSSIA.
>> I'M NOT SUGGESTING THEY DID
OR NOT, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
WHAT I DO KNOW IS THAT THEY WERE
AND TAKE OUT ADS.
EVERY CAMPAIGN REPUBLICAN,
DEMOCRAT, YOU PUT OUT YOUR
PROPAGANDA.
YOU ALWAYS DO.
IF PAID ADS ON TELEVISION
WEREN'T GOOD YOU WOULDN'T SEE
PEOPLE DO IT.
>> Laura: DOESN'T MEAN TRUMP
COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA.
IT MEANS RUSSIA IS GOOD AT WHAT
COORDINATION BETWEEN TRUMP AND
TO DETERMINE.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
THIS IS ABOUT BEING ATTACKED IN
A NEW WAY OF WARFARE.
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE GOING TO BE
UP TO THE TASK.
I THINK WE FELL ASLEEP AFTER THE
SOVIETS COLLAPSED.
I WAS IN COLLEGE AT DARTMOUTH, I
DON'T REMEMBER HOLLYWOOD
RALLYING TO RONALD REAGAN.
I REMEMBER THE OPPOSITE
HAPPENING.
>> BUT BEFORE THAT, I'M WAY
OLDER THAN YOU, AND WE HAD TO
HIDE UNDER DESKS.
>> Laura: BUT YOU WEREN'T
SUPPORTING REAGAN, YOU COULDN'T
STAND REAGAN.
>> I WASN'T IN SUPPORT OF
REAGAN.
>> Laura: HE TOOK ON THE
RUSSIANS, YOU'RE LIKE A MODERN
ASSURED DESTRUCTION.
NOW WE'RE BEYOND MUTUALLY
RUSSIA'S ECONOMY IS SMALLER THAN
FRANCE.
>> IT IS.
HERE'S WHAT IS SMART ABOUT
PUTIN.
WE BASICALLY BEAT THEM DURING
THE COLD WAR.
>> Laura: WE WANTS MOTHER RUSSIA
BACK, I KNOW, I KNOW.
>> THEY SPENT THEMSELVES INTO
OBLIVION TRYING TO --
LOT OF DIFFERENT PRESIDENTS
HELPED TO DO THAT.
BUT PUTIN FIGURED OUT FOR A HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS, VERY
INEXPENSIVE THING, I CAN
WEAPONIZE CYBER WAR.
WHAT PEOPLE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND,
THE CAPACITY THAT CYBER WAR, NOT
JUST INVADING THE ELECTION,
OBAMA, TWIENT GET TO THE FUN
SNUFF A MOMENT.
>> THIS ISN'T THE FUN STUFF?
>> Laura: FOR ME, TALKING THE B.
THE OTHER STUFF IS FUN, YOU
TALKING ABOUT POLITICS.
BUT PUTIN DID PRETTY WELL IN THE
OBAMA YEARS.
WENT INTO CRIMEA, OBVIOUSLY, THE
UKRAINE, OBVIOUSLY GREW HIS
POPULARITY AT HOME.
THE IDEA THAT TRUMP WOULD BE A
"NIRVANA" FOR PUTIN I DIDN'T GET
THAT.
HE DID REALLY WELL IN THE
OBAMA-CLINTON ERA, DIDN'T DOT
RESET, IT FAILED.
>> BUT OBAMA DID, KNOW, WHETHER
REMOVING THOSE SANCTIONS.
WE HAVE SANCTIONS PASSED BY 98-2
IN THE SENATE VIRTUALLY
EVERYBODY --
>> Laura: RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, I KNOW.
AT SOME POINT THIS BECOMES
COMICAL, FUNNIER THAN THE STUFF
YOU PRODUCE.
ARE YOU WORRIED THAT --
>> YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT THIS
STUFF?
>> Laura: I DO CARE BUT I THINK
YOU'RE GOING DOWN THE WRONG
RABBIT HOLE, IT'S A RABBIT HOLE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT POLITICS
DOES TO ART.
>> OKAY.
>> Laura: POLITICS AND ART HAVE
ALWAYS HAD A CONNECTION.
>> YEAH.
>> Laura: ALWAYS A CONNECTION.
HEADS, SAY THAT THERE'S A BLACK
LIST IN HOLLYWOOD, IF YOU
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR TRUMP IT'S
LIKE HARVEY WEINSTEIN DID, YOU
DON'T WORK.
>> I DON'T KNOW THERE IS A
ACTORS ARE LIBERAL, NO QUESTION
ABOUT THAT.
AND THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT.
BECAUSE A LIBERAL, HAVE A VERY
CLINTON, IN THE OVAL OFFICE, I
DEMOCRATS?
REPUBLICANS KNOW THEY'RE RIGHT.
DEMOCRATS ENTERTAIN THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THEY MIGHT BE
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE LIBERALS
DRAWN TO THE ARTS.
BECAUSE IT'S MORE OF AN
>> Laura: I LOVE IT, IT'S
FANTASTIC.
ARE YOU BOTHERED, LOOKING BACK
IN THE '70s, I GREW UP WATCHING
YOU AS MICHAEL STIVIC, THE
LIBERAL DO-GOODER ON ALL IN THE
FAMILY.
DID IT BUG YOU THAT ARCHIE
HE WAS A LIBERAL THAT PLAYED
THIS BLUE COLLAR GUY.
HE HAD A LOVEABLE SIDE TO HIM.
>> HE DID.
WE GOT A LOT OF CRITICISM
BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE --
>> Laura: LOVED HIM.
>> THEY SAID HOW DARE YOU MAKE A
LOVEABLE BIG ON THE.
WE SAID HE'S A HUMAN BEING, HE
LOVES HIS WIFE, LOVES HIS
DAUGHTER.
AND THAT MAKES HIM HUMAN.
>> Laura: YOU SAID TRUMP IS A
RACIST --
>> WELL HE IS.
WOULD HANG AROUND WITH -- I
DON'T HANG AROUND WITH HIM BUT
I'VE KNOWN HIM FOR 15 YEARS.
I WILL TELL YOU YOU HAVE TO
BELIEVE ME.
>> I'LL LISTEN.
>> Laura: YOU MIGHT THINK --
>> I GO BY WHAT HE SAYS.
>> Laura: DISAGREE WITH
ABOUT OBAMA, WHY DID HE SPREAD
>> THAT'S A VERY RACIST THING.
>> Laura: HE IS NOT A RACIST, HE
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN FRIENDS WITH
OPRAH WINFREY.
>> AND WHY DOES HE SAY THERE'S
GOOD ON BOTH SIDES WHEN THERE'S
NAZIS MARCHING?
>> Laura: SOMETIMES HE ISN'T THE
MOST PRECISE IN HIS LINGUISTICS.
>> AND S-HOLE COUNTRIES?
>> Laura: LIKE OBAMA SAID
S-STORM, AND LINDSAY GRAHAM, THE
HELL HOLE OF CENTRAL AMERICA?
>> I'VE MET HIM ONE TIME.
>> Laura: AND YOU THOUGHT HE WAS
NAR ASSIST.
LIKE NO ONE IN THIS TOWN IS A
NARCICISSTIC.
YOU HANG OUT WITH THE PEOPLE WHO
READ OTHER PEOPLE'S LINES FOR A
LIVING.
>> YOU BET.
>> Laura: THEY LOOK AT
THEMSELVES IN THE MIRROR ALL
DAY.
I'M ON TELEVISION TOO, BUT LOOK
OUT, COME O.
>> I WORK WITH THE BIGGEST NAR
SISISTS IN THE WORLD.
ACTORS ARE THE BIGGEST NAR
ASSISTS IN THE WORLD.
THEY WANT ATTENTION, WANT TO BE
LOVED, THEY DON'T EVEN COME
CLOSE TO THIS GUY IN THE ONE
TIME I SPENT WITH HIM.
I WAS WITH HIM, WITH BILLY
>> Laura: ANOTHER PERSON I
ADORE.
>> AT HIS HOTEL FOR A FIGHT.
AND HE BASICALLY ONLY TALKED
ABOUT HIMSELF THE WHOLE TIME.
>> Laura: THAT'S A SHOCK.
YOU MIGHT BE BETTER -- HE MIGHT
BE BETTER AT HIDING IT.
CLINTON, OBAMA, COME ON, REAGAN
WAS NOT NARCISISTIC, JFK.
>> YOU GET TO THAT POSITION YOU
NEED THAT, YOU NEED TO BE LOVED.
>> Laura: SO ARCHIE, PEOPLE
COMPARE TRUMP TO ARCHIE BUNKER,
FINE, WHATEVER.
>> THEY'RE BOTH FROM QUEENS.
>> Laura: THEY'RE LOVEABLE.
BUT YOU DON'T SEE ANYTHING
REDEEMING IN DONALD TRUMP, NOT
ONE THING?
>> I DON'T SEE HIM BEING
STAIRS TO GET INTO THE AIR FORCE
ONE, AND IT'S RAINING, AND HE
HAS THE UMBRELLA --
>> Laura: YOU WATCH HIM CLOSELY.
>> I MEAN THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
YOU OBSERVE PEOPLE.
AND HIS KID, AND MELANIA GETTING
RAINED ON AND HE DOESN'T -- IT'S
JUST A THING ABOUT LOOKING OF
THE FOR OTHER PEOPLE.
CARING ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE.
>> Laura: GOOD ECONOMY?
>> WELL THAT'S NOT ABOUT CARING.
I'M TAUNGING ABOUT A HUMAN
BEING -- TALKING ABOUT A HUMAN
CARING BEING LOVING PERSON.
>> Laura: GOVERNMENT ISN'T LOVE.
>> I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENT.
I'M NOT SAYING THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD LOVE, I'M TALKING ABOUT
HIM AS HUMAN BEING.
>> Laura: BACK TO MY QUESTION,
YOU'RE JUDGING HIS FAMILY.
>> NOT HIS FAMILY, I'M JUDGING
HIS BEHAVIOR.
>> Laura: OKAY, BILL CLINTON GOT
ORAL SEX IN THE OVAL OFFICE WHEN
HIS WIFE WAS SLEEPING.
>> HE DID?
>> Laura: SLEEPING IN THE
RESIDENCE.
WE HAD LBJ WHO YOU DID A MOVIE
ABOUT, YOU SAID REALLY NICE
THINGS ABOUT LBJ, FASCINATING
CHARACTER.
BUT I THINK HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
THE VIETNAM WAR HE WOULD HAVE
GONE DOWN AS ONE OF THE GREATEST
PRESIDENTS OF ALL TIME, SECOND
TO ROOSEVELT, PASSED MORE
LEGISLATION THAN ANYBODY.
>> TRUE.
>> Laura: HE HAD ANOTHER SIDE TO
HIM.
>> YES, HE DID.
>> Laura: URINATING INTO THE
SINK, INVITING PEOPLE INTO HIS
BATHROOM.
>> I SHOWED THE BATHROOM SCENE.
>> Laura: EXPOSING HIS PRIVATE
PARTS.
NOTHING SURPRISES THE BIOGRAPHER
OF LYNDON BAINES JOHNSON.
BRAG ABOUT HIS WOMANIZING, SAID
HE WAS MORE OF A WOMANIZER THAN
JFK.
>> WHAT'S THE POINT?
>> Laura: HE HAD A LOT OF FLAWS
BY --
>> Laura: YOU DON'T LIKE HIS
POLICIES, THAT'S FINE.
>> I DON'T LIKE THE WAY HE
CONDUCTS HIS LIFE.
THE WAY HE TREATS OTHER PEOPLE.
>> Laura: YOU DID A MOVIE ABOUT
LBJ WHO HAD HORRIBLE PERSONAL
FLAWS.
>> I DON'T LIKE MAN WHO GOES
LIKE THIS WITH TOWELS, WITH
PAPER TOWELS.
I DON'T LIKE THAT.
I DON'T LIKE THE WAY HE TROETS
OTHER PEOPLE.
>> Laura: OKAY.
SO THE PAPER TOWEL THROW?
IS THIS ABOUT HOUSTON, THE
HURRICANE DEAL?
>> YOU'RE MAKING REALLY BAD
ARGUMENTS HERE.
>> Laura: I DON'T THINK SO.
YOU'RE SMART AS HELL, WHEN I
MAKE THAT COMMENT, I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE WAY, HIS BEHAVIOR, THE
WAY IN WHICH HE BEHAVES TOWARD
OTHER PEOPLE.
THAT'S ALL I'M TALKING ABOUT.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT ANYTHING
JUST BEFORE WE LET YOU GO, YOUR
DAD IS SUCH AN AMAZING MAN AND
TALENT.
DIFFERENCES AND THE TENSION,
>> Laura: I DON'T THINK -- IT'S
A CONVERSATION.
AGAIN, ROB REINER, IS SOME ONE
WHO SHOULD BE LAUDED BECAUSE
HE'S SOME ONE WHO DOESN'T AGREE
COMES IN FOR A CONVERSATION.
AND I TELL YOU, REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS ON CAPITOL HILL, ROB,
A LOT OF THEM WON'T COME ON THIS
SHOW.
I READ LEGISLATION.
>> WHO?
LIVE LINDSAY GRAHAM, JOHN FLAKE,
JOHN McCAIN, CORY GARDNER, A LOT
OF REPUBLICANS AFRAID TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THEIR JOB.
AND I FIND THAT TO BE
DISTURBING.
THE FACT THAT YOU ARE WILLING
AND YOU'VE GONE ON WITH TUCKER,
O'REILLY.
THAT IS REALLY ADMIRABLE.
>> WE HAVE A CONVERSATION.
>> Laura: IT'S REALLY GOOD.
MORE PEOPLE SHOULD DO IT.
WE HAVE LOT IN COMMON BELIEVE IT
OR NOT, I LOVE YOUR CRAFT AND
LIFE.
YOUR DAD SMIS ONE I REALLY, REEL
HUH ADMIRE.
95 YEARS OLD.
SAYS IF I'M NOT IN THE OBITS I
EAT BREAKFAST.